you're a man that likes to enjoy
yourself I know that you you played in
the past we talked about video games you
play a lot of video games maybe a little
too much is that right I'd I have I've
played a tremendous amount of video
games and I played video games with you
by the way we've done that down a comic
combo yeah we did thank your ass if I
remember correctly I'm not throwing it
is saying I'm the worst player of video
games in the world all right and
befuddled by pong I don't get any
there's nothing I don't understand any
video game and so I'm easily beat but
I'll take the feather out of my cap on
your big victory uh yes I do I do I have
played a lot of video games and I do
love them I just I I kind of got to a
place in my life you know work was busy
and all that stuff and I I don't I think
I was playing like the last Zelda is
anybody gonna get this which by the way
I really want to get that in tennis
which that looks really awesome but
anyway whoo looks like yeah okay great
what's that that's me trying to get a
free Nintendo anyway apples already cut
me off I gotta go so you're done with
your done with dizzy yeah just now
you're trying to get a Nintendo switch
it's better funny backstage you said
Nintendo blows
so anybody uh so but you play a lot I do
I applied a lot of videos but I I think
I was playing the last Zelda which is
such a great franchise I played all of
them since I was a kid and it had like a
tally like a lot of games now it will
tell you how long you played the game
and I got to the end of the game and I'm
like a completionist I'm gonna find all
the loot all the treasure do all the
side quests all that stuff and I think
like I beat it and I was so thrilled I
was like yes and I I looked at the
screen and it was something like you've
been playing this for eight months or
something he was so long and then I
looked around and I realized I have
nobody to even celebrate with it's just
me and a bunch of fictitious characters
on a screen you don't even get like a
real trophy you've just got a digital
thing that says congratulations you've
wasted your time like I don't it would
be great if they could somehow then show
you a montage of the life you would have
lived
[Applause]
here's the places you'd of God memories
you to shared like Gwyneth Paltrow and
sliding doors it's like oh did I make
that subway card nobody know what it
pops no no I think I saw it guys when it
came out yeah sure
you